OK, let’s be honest, guys.
When’s the last time you washed your pants?
Just think about it.
Hey clothes-wearers, Trace here for DNews.
Some of us wash our clothes twice a week,
some of us wash them...well, let’s just
say I wash them less.
But is that bad?
What health risk could there possibly be from
wearing that T-shirt for the 20th time?
Well, human skin sheds around 500 million
skin cells a day.
Add in all the dirt, sweat and oil that builds
up on our skin, and you’ve got yourself
a hotbed for bacteria to breed and multiply.
But not all of these are bad.
In fact, normal human skin is covered in hundreds
of microbes -- including bacteria that may
help protect you from diseases.
But there are some harmful bacteria that could
get onto your clothes.
A professor at London School of Hygiene and
Tropical Medicine found that many pathogens
can remain on the surface of fabrics for long
periods, depending on the strain and the viability
of the fabric itself.
E. coli , for example, can remain on fabrics
for hours.
Salmonella can last up to 24 weeks on fabric,
and strains of fungi for several weeks as
well.
And Staphylococcus, which causes staph infections,
has been found to survive for weeks or even
months.
And, one of the most common causes of skin
infection, Methicillin-resistant Staphylococcus
aureus (or MRSA), can be easily transferred
from our skin to our clothes and towels and
spread by sharing them.
Another offender is our dirty underwear.
The average undergarment harbors a tenth of
a gram of fecal matter, which can carry a
number of viruses and bacteria such as hepatitis
A, norovirus, salmonella and E. coli.
I'm sure you're starting the washing machine
right now, and maybe you should.
Because according to the London School of
Hygiene and Tropical Medicine, again, bacteria
begin to multiply the longer you wear your
clothes without washing, and if you give them
enough time to build up, even your washing
machine will have a hard time removing them.
The thing is, scientific studies on how often
you should wash clothing are thin on the ground,
with many being funded by corporations with
a vested interest in the outcome.
For example, a study done by a University
of Arizona researcher was paid for by Clorox
bleach, found bacteria from your laundry might
spread through the washing machine during
cleaning and end up on future loads.
And another study done by the same researcher
in 2007 (likely funded by Clorox) found 92
to 99% of viruses were killed, but recommended
bleaching your machine anyway.
However, the CDC in the US and the National
Health Services in England both recommends
using simple heat.
The NHS says to use water at a temperature
of 60 C (140 F) to kill bacteria -- that would
be the HOT setting.
And they suggest running the washing machine
empty or with chemical disinfectant once a
week to decontaminate it.
And the CDC says to dry on hot for a long
while to ensure some sterilization.
More heat is better, but they also realize
that can be a fire hazard.
So, Philip Tierno from the New York University
School of Medicine says that while cooler
temperatures could keep the bacteria living
in the washing machine, drying clothes in
the sun, can kill bacteria with ultraviolet
radiation!
So, there are options, if you're worried!
Although there could be a risk of infection
with dirty laundry in your home, the International
Scientific Forum on Home Hygiene says that
the risks are probably less than if you touch
a solid surface, a food, or have direct contact
with someone else’s skin.
This is because pathogens can survive better
on hard surfaces than they can on fabric,
and because while we constantly touch the
same hard surfaces like door handles, we don’t
all touch each other’s clothing.
. Still, if you can’t remember the last
time your tshirt saw the inside of a washing
machine, maybe it’s time to get on that.
Do you guys have a science question about
stuff around your house?
Let us know in the comments, make sure you
subscribe for more DNews and check out this
video about why we even smell in the first
place.
Cause, where else are your clothes gonna get
that stank?